même la directrice chef de l'Inspection
générale de la police nationale monsieur
le chef de l'Inspection générale de la
gendarmerie générale nous avons le
plaisir de vous recevoir ce matin pour
une audition conjointe de Madame Agnès
Thibault le cuivre directrice et chef de
l'Inspection générale de la police
nationale qui est par ailleurs magistral
de carrière et le général Alain Pidou
qui est chef de l'Inspection générale de
la gendarmerie nationale d'abord je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté le principe de
cette audition comme ces modalités c'est
à dire une audition commune pour que on
puisse mieux connaître et contrôler le
travail de vos inspections qui jouent un
rôle irremplaçable dans le contrôle des
forces de sécurité j'en profite pour
vous préciser que cette audition a été
organisée avant les émeutes urbaines et
qu'elle n'est pas destinée à traiter des
affaires en cours mais bien faire un
bilan qui pourra devenir annuel de
l'activité des inspections générales
sur les violences urbaines de la fin
juin et du début juillet nous recevrons
le ministre de l'Intérieur la semaine
prochaine et je vous invite à poser vos
questions mises intérieur à ce moment-là
devant notre commission le 30 novembre
2020 nous présentons le bobo de la
sécurité le ministre d'intérieur avait
décrit ce qu'il appelait les 7 péchés
capitaux de la sécurité il parlait de la
formation de l'encadrement du matériel
de l'équipement la vidéo des effectifs
de maintien de l'ordre du lien entre la
police et la population et du rôle des
inspections il est ok également le lien
avec la justice qui fait l'objet débat
parlementaire actuellement surtout ces
sujets beaucoup ont été fait au travers
la lepnée qui a dégagé des moyens
importants certains se trouvent
d'ailleurs directement en chantier et
s'agissant des rôles des inspections le
problème n'est pas tant la qualité de
leur travail mais de faire mieux
connaître et mieux appliquer les
préconisations et les sanctions qu'elle
propose et c'est dans ce cadre que
plusieurs pistes avaient été envisagées
par le Président de la République lors
de la remise des conclusions du Bureau
de la sécurité
notamment la création d'une délégation
de parlementaire pour contrôler le
travail des inspections je connais le
travail des inspections délégations
parlementaires je suis moi-même membre
de la délégation de parlementaire au
renseignement et il m'a semblé inadapté
cette cette voici en revanche le débat
annuel contrôle parlementaire sur le
travail d'inspection me semble une
hypothèse à privilégier et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous organisons
aujourd'hui cette audition je précise
qu'elle fait suite également une visite
que nous avons conduite une première
d'ailleurs dans les locaux de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale le 13 le 23 mai dernier avec
Monsieur Rudy goes qui était d'ailleurs
le rapporteur de la loi sécurité globale
et donc nous étions les premiers élus à
les visiter les cette inspection
beaucoup de surprises sur le
fonctionnement de bonnes surprises par
ailleurs notamment sur les pratiques qui
sont qui sont les vôtres en matière de
testing dans les commissariats qui nous
ont beaucoup surprises et intéressés et
j'espère que c'est surprise nous
pourront les partager aujourd'hui devant
vous la commission ce que je vous
propose c'est de vous passer la parole
pour un propos introductif l'un et
l'autre pour commencer et ensuite chacun
de nos collègues auront une durée
maximale de deux minutes pour vous poser
leurs questions Madame la Directrice
vous avez la parole
ce président mesdames messieurs les
députés c'est avec le sens de la
responsabilité qui m'incombe en qualité
de chef de l'Inspection générale de la
police nationale que je me présente
aujourd'hui devant vous je vais dans un
instant dans les limites que vous avez
rappelé monsieur le Président à savoir
que je ne l'exprimerai pas aujourd'hui
sur des procédures judiciaires en cours
m'attacher à répondre avec les
interrogations qui sont pas essence
légitimes dans le cadre de votre
contrôle parlementaire mais je souhaite
d'abord précisément pour vous permettre
d'assurer ce contrôle en toute
connaissance de cause vous présenter
l'IGPN que j'ai l'honneur de diriger
depuis près d'un an à l'été 2022 ma
nomination sur proposition du ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer celle
d'un magistrat vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président de l'ordre
judiciaire une première alors qu'une
inspection avait été toujours dirigée
par un policier actif a pu suscité
crainte critique attente défiance contre
les policiers affichage avancés au temps
de propos que j'ai pu entendre et qu'il
ne m'appartenait et ne m'appartient
évidemment pas de commenter autrement
que par l'action déployer avec mes
équipes depuis un an et à qui vont
permettre ici de rendre hommage car mon
action n'a de sens qu'avec celle des
équipes que je dirige au travers de
lignes directrices de lisibilité rigueur
objectivité impartialité transparence et
aussi fierté comme le signe
d'appartenance à une inspection certes
parfois scrutée crainte ou dénigré mais
avant tout nécessaire et souhaitons le
utile pour tous et comprise de tous mes
équipes d'abord avant d'aborder ensuite
l'émission
l'IGPN compte dans ses effectifs une
diversité de profil étant précisé que
nous sommes à date 276
276 dont 203 policiers actifs de toux
Grad mais aussi des fonctionnaires
d'autres corps de la fonction publique
des contractuels un magistrat de l'ordre
administratif des personnels
administratifs des apprentis vous
l'aurez compris je m'inscris en faux
contre l'idée d'un entre soi
j'en veux pour preuve la capacité des
policiers qui m'entourent à écouter
entendre comprendre intégrer et une
Phinée à riposter aux critiques
récurrentes blanchisseuses pendant cité
qu'une qui leur sont faites pour se
prémunir de tout biais corporatifs tout
en ayant une parfaite appréhension de la
réalité vécue par leurs collègues
policiers de terrain le révèle enfin nos
constants échanges avec les directions
de la police nationale mais aussi avec
les organisations syndicales
professionnelles mais également avec les
autorités externes de contrôle
défenseurs des droits contre le général
des lieux de privation de liberté mais
encore avec les associations qui œuvrent
au rapprochement de la police et de la
population aux chercheurs aux
universitaires à cet égard il est
intéressant de relever que le comité
d'évaluation de la déontologie de la
police nationale dont la création avait
été actée fin 2020 par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outre-mer et porter
par la chef de l'Inspection générale de
la police nationale il réunit son ma
présidente les directions de police mais
aussi les autorités externes de contrôle
un magistrat lors judiciaire un
magistrat de l'ordre administratif un
représentant du Conseil National des
Barreaux un chercheur universitaire un
membre d'une association rapprochant la
police et la population
ce comité d'évaluation de la déontologie
de la police nationale démontre la
capacité de l'institution à interroger
ces pratiques c'est dans ce contexte à
la fois de connexion aux réalités du
terrain et de connexion aux enjeux
sociétaux que nos missions sont
réalisées par celles et ceux qui les
animent j'en viens donc aux missions qui
sont les nôtres elles sont structurées
autour de trois sous-directions que je
vais rapidement prévoquer sans
hiérarchisation entre elles la
sous-direction des enquêtes
administratives et judiciaires d'abord
la plus connue sans conteste elle est
composée de 121 enquêteurs répartis en
une division nationale des enquêtes et
en 8 délégations dans chaque zone de
défense et un bureau elles sont
coordonnées par une unité de
coordination des enquêtes et cette
sous-direction comprend également les
plateformes de l'IGPN la plateforme ne
signalement destinée aux usagers et la
plateforme signal discret destiné aux
policiers
l'IGPN vous le savez tous est un service
national judiciaire spécialisé
d'enquêtes qui ne traite par définition
pas de toutes les affaires qui mettent
en cause les policiers nous avons à
connaître celle qui revêt un caractère
de gravité ou de complicité ou celle
encore retentissement particulièrement
important en 2022 l'IGPN a été saisi par
l'autorité judiciaire parquée magistrat
instructeur sous la direction de
laquelle elle agit et à qui elle
rencontre de
d'un certain nombre d'enquêtes à savoir
1065 enquête judiciaire
parallèlement à ces enquêtes judiciaires
qui vise à rassembler des preuves à
charge et à décharge pour caractériser
les éléments constitutifs d'une
infraction pénale au nom du devoir de
réaction de l'administration l'IGPN
procède à des enquêtes administratives
prédisciplinaires à l'effet de recherche
si des manquements professionnels ou
déontologiques ont été commis nous avons
ouvert en 2022 192 enquêtes
administratives je vais enfin ici
rappeler que le rôle de l'IGPN s'arrête
à la proposition d'engagement de
poursuite disciplinaire ou de sanctions
elle est en aucun cas compétente en
matière de prononcé de sanction
aux côtés de cette sous-direction des
enquêtes ensuite la sous-direction des
inspections évaluation et audites qui
est organisée autour de deux
départements un département des
inspections et évaluations un
département de l'audit interne les
missions d'inspection sont une activité
de contrôle de mise en oeuvre lorsque un
événement un acte ou un comportement
apparaissent de nature à compromettre le
déroulé normal de l'activité policière
il s'agit alors pour l'inspection
d'analyser les dysfonctionnements
dénoncées et de proposer des mesures
correctives à court ou moyen terme
l'émission d'évaluation porte quant à
elle sur une organisation un service la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique publique
ou d'une réforme et elle vise à mesurer
l'atteinte des objectifs tout autant que
la bonne utilisation des moyens à louer
elles sont réalisées dans une démarche
essentiellement prospective
la démarche d'audit interne indépendante
et objective exerce sa mission d'enquête
domaines le métier comptable et
budgétaire temps de travail technologies
c'est ce département de l'audit interne
qui procède au testing autrement appelé
contre l'inopiné que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le Président à savoir
l'évaluation de l'accueil dans les
services de police une mission qui est
essentielle dans la qualité de l'accueil
dans les services de police comme dans
tout service public d'ailleurs doit être
sans cesse questionner analyser et suivi
pour tendre vers une amélioration
croissante et chargée d'inspection et
auditeurs internes ont en charge le
suivi des recommandations sans se suivit
l'effectivité de nos travaux
interrogerait et je souhaite renforcer
ce suivi de nos recommandations enfin la
sous-direction de l'analyse du conseil
de l'accompagnement et de la maîtrise
des risques qui comprend trois
structures distinctes le cabinet de
l'analyse de la déontologie et de la
règle à l'instar de sa dénomination il
procède notamment à des analyses et
conseils juridiques aussi bien pour les
directions sur des doctrines d'emploi
par exemple que pour les policiers de
terrain sur des interrogations
pragmatiques juridiques
il conduit aussi le suivi et l'analyse
de deux applications qui sont
essentielles dans un fonctionnement
démocratique que sont le traitement
relatif au suivi de l'usage des armes et
le recensement des personnes blessées ou
décédées lors des missions de Service de
police
c'est ce service en fin qui traite les
demandes qui me sont faites en ma
qualité de référente déontologue de la
police nationale
cette sous-direction ensuite comporte
une mission d'appui et de conseils que
nous appelons Mac en interne
l'implantation d'un cabinet internalisé
de conseils à l'IGPN initié en 2013 au
profit de l'ensemble des directions de
la police nationale et de la préfecture
de police est composée pour moitié en
pour moitié de policiers actifs
expérimentés et pour moitié de
contractuel issus de grands cabinets
privés de conseils cette mission doit
être soulignée à mon sens d'une part au
regard de sa capacité de par sa
composition à apporter une offre de
conseil en organisation qui soit
connecté à l'attente du policier tout en
utilisant des outils qui ont fait leurs
preuves dans le privé et d'autre part au
regard de l'internalisation évidente du
coup
enfin dans cette sous-direction
l'analyse de la maîtrise des activités
et des risques que nous appelons amaris
depuis 2016 la police nationale s'est
engagée dans cette démarche capitale de
maîtrise des risques métiers pour
sécuriser le fonctionnement des services
et éviter que dysfonctionnements
surviennent
cette structure est chargée de conduire
une démarche commune au moyen de
méthodes et d'outils partagés à savoir
une base d'analyse des incidents et des
accidents de la police nationale
l'élaboration de fiches très pratiques
aux pratiques à destination des
policiers de terrain sur tel ou tel
risque récurrents ou signalé le
déploiement dans les services de police
d'un logiciel de contrôle des risques
les l'élaboration encore de
cartographies des risques l'objectif de
cette mission est donc double améliorer
le fonctionnement des services en
décelant en analysant en anticipant les
risques et par la même sécuriser les
policiers dans l'exercice de leur métier
voici Monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés rapidement
dressées une présentation générale de
l'ensemble des missions l'IGPN à
laquelle j'ajoute une action socle qui
est celle de la formation dispensée par
l'ensemble des agents de l'IGPN aux
policiers de tout grade à titre
d'exemple la formation en matière de
déontologie au cadre légal en matière
d'usage des armes que ce soit en droit
commun ou en maintien de l'ordre à la
maîtrise des risques entre autres
en conclusion
l'inspection que je porte ambitionne
devrait au rapprochement de la police et
des usagers en étant d'une part guidée
par le souci de la vérité dû à notre
concitoyens en étant d'autre part
intraitables avec les policiers qui
doivent l'être et en étant en appui en
accompagnement au soutien de tous les
autres cette démarche nous la devons à
l'institution police nationale en haute
qualité d'organes de contrôle interne
Luda devons à chaque policier nous la
devons enfin et surtout à la population
pour renforcer le lien de confiance avec
sa police je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Monsieur le Directeur de
l'inspection générale de la gendarmerie
nationale général vous avez la parole
merci
merci pas le directeur je suis plutôt le
chef parce que je suis pas un directeur
de l'administration centrale et
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas rattaché à la
DGGN et d'ailleurs on n'est pas sur le
site d'Issy-les-Moulineaux on est à
Malakoff mais merci monsieur le
Président merci mesdames et messieurs
les députés de votre accueil ce matin
ici cette grande première
très honnêtement c'est pour moi un peu
l'aboutissement d'un parcours car depuis
trois années trois années que je suis la
tête de l'iggn et que je vais quitter
dans quelques jours moins de 20 jours
d'ailleurs j'ai eu la volonté de mettre
en œuvre les conditions de la
redevabilité de respecter cette
relèveabilité de notre action à tout le
niveau et maintenant devant vous la
représentation nationale
alors que le rapport d'activité de
l'iggène le rapport d'activité 2022
vient d'être rendu public il me semble
vraiment naturel de rendre des comptes
sur l'état de santé de la gendarmerie
nationale en matière de déontologie
depuis 2020 je n'ai eu de cesse de
concrétiser ma volonté d'ouverture et de
transparence
le bobo de la sécurité je le pense
réellement était un accélérateur de
notre transformation même si j'avais
exprimé entièrement mes souhaits de
changement
j'ai toujours eu
conscience comme Agnès vient de le dire
d'ailleurs que le cœur du sujet porte
sur le lien de confiance entre les
forces de sécurité intérieure et la
population
ce lien de confiance en fait il passe
bien sûr par un travail bien fait
une rigueur dans l'exécution des
missions une disponibilité de nos
gendarmes au profit de leur concitoyen
mais il passe peut-être essentiellement
par une exemplarité une excentrité de
nos gendarmes dans l'exécution de leur
mission dans leur prise de parole et en
fait réellement dans leur comportement
au quotidien
les inspections générales ont une
mission essentielle à mes yeux de
contrôle et d'enquêtes sans oublier la
dynamique à maintenir en matière de
prévention que j'évoquerai un peu plus
tard
le ministre mais surtout le dggen pour
moi doit disposer de ces outils pour
veiller à la qualité du travail
relevez éventuellement les fautes et
donc garantir une exigence nécessaire
dans notre métier sachant que vous en
êtes bien conscient nous avons des
pouvoirs exorbitants du droit commun
pour faire en sorte notamment
que le faible soit protégé ne l'oublions
pas
alors l'iggn l'iggène en fait ce sont
117 personnels qui se consacrent à cette
exigence d'exemplarité qui est pour moi
synonyme de légitimité
nous sommes organisés pour traiter les
signalements externes comme interne
sachez que l'an dernier nous avons
enregistré 5000
580 signalements externes donc
2952 ont été recueillis sur notre
plateforme à l'iggn
retenez bien que sur ces 2900 finalement
il nous en avons que 88
qui tombent dans notre compétence
puisque nous avons beaucoup de
sollicitations pour des contestations
d'infraction routières de conflits
privés ou de cas qui fait déjà l'objet
qui décade qui font déjà l'objet de ces
injures
11,7% des signalements de notre
compétence je retiens relève des
manquements
notamment en matière d'accueil dans les
brigades de gendarmerie et aussi en
matière de prise de plainte
ce sont peu de cas en fait au regard de
la multitude des personnes qui viennent
dans les unités mais sachez que tous les
fautifs sont systématiquement
sanctionnés alors pour votre information
sachez que
2992 sanctions disciplinaires ont été
prises en 2022 dont 19 radiations des
cadres 12 résiliations de contrats et
aussi
71 blame du ministre ce qui correspond à
la sanction la plus haute du que nous
appelons le groupe 1 sanctions qui
restent dans le dossier du militaire
pendant 10 ans
l'iggène et bien sûr connu pour ces
enquêtes judiciaires
783 enquêtes judiciaires ont été
conduites en 2022 dans 54 par le bej
c'est-à-dire le bureau des enquêtes
judiciaires de l'iggn sachez
qu'actuellement nous avons un
portefeuille comme on appelle 123
enquêtes judiciaires
chaque enquête judiciaire je le rappelle
est placé sous le contrôle des
magistrats que ce soit les procureurs à
la République ou les juges
d'instructions
le bej aussi est systématiquement saisie
lors des usages des âmes mortels
concrètement
en 2022 nous avons eu 4
usages des armes mortels
usage
situation opérationnelle d'usage des
armes alors je reviens sur ce chiffre de
62 ce chiffre comme vous avez pu le voir
peut-être dans d'autres rapports
d'activités
paru c'est le plus faible qui enregistré
depuis plus de 10 ans
j'ai souhaité aussi depuis deux ans
faire acte de transparence comme je l'ai
vu évoqué et évoquer l'ensemble des
personnes décédées blessées blessés des
ITT de plus de huit jours et dans le
rapport vous trouverez la liste de tous
les faits et toutes les personnes qui
ont été soit décédés soit à l'action
liée à une action de la gendarmerie soit
blessée
cette maîtrise de l'emploi de la force
62 usages des armes seulement est à
mettre un regard avec l'importance
croissante depuis 10 ans du nombre de
gendarmes agressés nous avons eu
4354 agressions en 2022 ayant
occasionné
2462 blessés concrètement retenez qu'en
10 ans nous avons multiplié par deux le
nombre de gendarmes blessés en
intervention
alors je ne voudrais pas m'enfermer dans
une litanie de chiffres dont je souhaite
conclure en rappelant ici le travail qui
est réalisé avait les services du
défenseur des droits le Défenseur des
droits qui nous a saisi à 36 reprises
l'an dernier
au-delà du contrôle parlementaire de
votre ressort et que quand met en oeuvre
aujourd'hui le rôle du pôle déontologie
de la sécurité du Défenseur des droits
se contrôlent externe au regard du
contrôle interne que nous connaissons
est essentiel à mes yeux
à mon initiative une réunion annuelle
permet de faire le point sur les
modalités de saisine avec le Défenseur
des droits d'expliquer aussi nos
divergences dans la perception de
certaines de certains points et ne nous
en avons nous avons aussi organisé des
immersions en gendarmerie au profit des
unités dans aussi des unités au profit
des juristes du défi du DDD pour qui
comprennent les conditions d'action et
de travail de nos gendarmes
sachez que cette même dynamique existe
avec la contrôlage générale des lieux de
privation de liberté et j'ai souhaité
ouvrir les portes du diégène aux
chercheurs
et parfois à des journalistes
enfin au-delà des rapports d'activités
qui sont en ligne maintenant les autres
rapports notamment d'audit
sont rendus publics conformément aux
orientations arrêtées à l'issue du
Beauvau de la sécurité
je ne saurais terminé ce propos
introductif sans rappeler l'impulsion
que j'ai souhaité donner en matière de
prévention notamment par la parution en
septembre 2022 il y a moins d'un an du
plan d'action déontologie de la
gendarmerie qui comprend 22 actions dont
la majorité sont d'ores et des gens
engagés
au-delà des alertes déontologiques sont
diffusées et des kits pédagogiques sont
mis à disposition jusqu'à l'échelon de
la brigade ces brigades que vous
connaissez bien
au-delà la création du corps donateur
national pour le tir en 2022 au sein de
l'iggn est venu aussi renforcer
l'impératif identifié dans ce domaine
sensible vous le savez
dans cette démarche je tiens aussi pour
finir comme la chef de l'IGPN un mètre
en relief un relief le travail qui est
fait en matière de formation
l'iggène entretient intervient dans
toutes les étapes
lors des séminaires de préparation au
poste de commandement et nous associons
aussi le conseil de la fonction
militaire de la gendarmerie notre
structure pardon de concertation de
dialogues internes
dans la prévention du risque
déontologique concrètement ce sont plus
de 4000 personnels qui sont formés
annuellement par l'iggènes et l'ensemble
de l'enchaîne de la chaîne de formation
est impliquée comme nous avons ici de le
mettre en valeur dans le rapport
d'activité 2022 je vous remercie de
votre écoute
merci donc je vais donner la parole pour
des questions on commence par Monsieur
Thomas Rudigoz pour une note 2 minutes
je rappelle
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice de l'IGPN mon général je vous
remercie pour vous exposés respectifs
qui montrent l'étendue de votre travail
qui vous s’éliminent pas aux affaires à
retentissement médiatique mais qui est
bien plus profond pour s'assurer que les
comportements fautifs de nos
fonctionnaires puissent recevoir une
sanction administrative comme vous nous
l'aviez dit Madame la Directrice de
notre visite de l'IGPN avec le président
Houlier finalement beaucoup parlent de
l'IGPN et souvent pour la critiquer mais
finalement peu la connaissent et je
pense en général que c'est à peu près la
même chose pour les GIGN votre travail
est essentiel car aucun soupçon ne doit
pouvoir peser sur le travail des forces
de l'ordre c'est la condition de la
confiance des Français dans leur police
et la gendarmerie vous nous l'avez bien
précisé donc en premier lieu je voudrais
dire que nous ne pouvons laisser croire
qu'il y aurait une impunité au sein de
nos forces de l'ordre d'abord parce que
c'est faux il y a donc deux autorités
administratives que vous représentez
ainsi que l'autorité judiciaire qui mène
des enquêtes de grande qualité et qui
conduisent à des sanctions ensuite parce
que on laisserait penser à nos
concitoyens que des institutions
républicaines des tenteries de la force
légitime ne sont pas contrôlées et donc
non sanctionné excusez-moi
les gendarmes et les policiers sont
parmi les fonctionnaires au contraire
les plus contrôlés et sanctionnés de
l'administration française et les
chiffres que vous venez de nous
communiquer le montrent et enfin parce
que nous renforçons année après année
les moyens de contrôle notamment
technologique par exemple avec la
généralisation des caméras piétons la
locomique que nous avons voté récemment
vient rajouter une série d'outils et de
moyens supplémentaires donnés au
ministère de la même intérieur comme une
modernisation des plateformes de
signalement avec un outil de suivi des
sanctions ainsi qu'un renforcement des
saisies communes avec l'Inspection
générale de l'administration j'aurais
donc deux questions Madame la Directrice
mon Général quelle est l'efficacité des
caméras piétons dans le signalement des
infractions signalées à vos services et
l'utilité des éléments récoltés
quelle évolution législative vous
semblerait nécessaire pour renforcer
l'efficacité des missions de vos agents
je vous remercie merci Monsieur Jordan
Guitton
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice de l'IGPN Monsieur le Chef de
l'hygiène chers collègues permettez-moi
un propos luminaire de rappeler le
soutien du groupe rassemblement national
l'ensemble de nos forces de l'ordre je
vais également rendre hommage ici au
dizaines de décès au sein de la police
et la gendarmerie depuis le début de
l'année au plus de 800 policiers
gendarmes blessés durant les émeutes en
tant qu'élus nous devons soutenir nos
forces de l'ordre tant dans l'exercice
de leur fonction que dans la
valorisation de leur profession nous
savons qui sont l'une des professions
les plus contrôlées en France de par
votre travail et d'ailleurs les Français
leur font largement confiance selon un
sondage Ifop commandé par le point plus
de 84% des Français ont confiance en un
gendarmerie et près de 70% vers la
police cela reflète la qualité de
l'institution et de votre travail donc
voici mes questions qui se prêtent à la
fois votre expérience à votre travail
pourriez-vous tout d'abord nous préciser
le rythme et les conditions de travail
des policiers et des gendarmes notamment
vis-à-vis de l'acceptabilité de la
réforme des retraites qui va les
contraintes de travail deux ans de plus
l'évolution de ces dernières années ce
rythme et de ses conditions de travail
quel serait les solutions pour lutter
contre les non pourvu je pense notamment
la ruralité pour la gendarmerie les
nombreuses heures supplémentaires
affectent-elles le moral des forces de
l'ordre selon votre expérience est-ce
que des réservistes intègrent la
gendarmerie définitivement et comment
jugez-vous leur travail et le rapport
pensez vous que les émeutes récentes
entraînent des conditions de travail
dégradées affectent-elles les morales
des forces de l'ordre et quelle solution
trouvez-vous en interne pour améliorer
leurs conditions de travail
vis-à-vis de l'année 2024 pensez-vous
que les Jeux olympiques sont
susceptibles de venir modifier les
conditions de travail la qualité de
travail des forces de l'ordre et
pensez-vous qu'il y aura des territoires
légèrement abandonnés de par la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre sur
Paris vos services et vous nous
tuent-ils du coup en fonction de l'année
2024 il me semble que ces questions
importantes aux Français et j'aimerais
en dernière question ouvrir et vous
poser une question importante sur les
nouvelles technologies pensez-vous que
les drones les caméras de
vidéoprotection caméra algorithmics
scanners corporel améliore le travail
quotidien des policiers des gendarmes
améliore le travail le travail et vos
services vis-à-vis des enquêtes et
pensez-vous qu'ils sont utiles pour le
travail des forces de l'ordre je vous
remercie merci d'avoir passé la parole à
Monsieur Jean-François coulème je pense
que c'est des questions qui mériteraient
d'être posée davantage aux mises
d'intérieur Monsieur Jean-François
Coulogne
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice il n'aura échappé à personne
que les sanctions disciplinaires
internes à la police prononcée pour
violence illégitime en brutalement
baissé depuis que Monsieur Macron est
président de la République en effet
jusqu'en 2017 on comptait une centaine
de sanctions par an et soudainement dès
2018 ce chiffre tombe à 20 ou 30 par an
selon des sources que personne ici ne
contredira puisqu'elle proviennent de
vos propres services Madame Agnès
Thibault le cuivre or selon le directeur
de recherche au CNRS sur cette même
période on constate une hausse de
l'usage de la force et des armes par la
police n'avait qu'une élévation très
nette du nombre de tirs de LBD et de
grenades
on pourrait donc imaginer que plus on
demande à la police intervenir plus il y
a des confrontations et plus il y a de
fautes c'est une question logique or
nous observons l'exact contraire depuis
la fin de la crise des gilets jaunes la
baisse des sanctions se prolonge les
chiffres sont parlants avant 2018 au
moins une trentaine de sanctions
disciplinaires du plus haut degré de
gravité était prononcé chaque année et
depuis 2018 ce chiffre est tombé à 2,5
par an aucune exclusion définitive n'a
été prononcée pour les policiers
violents contre une dizaine par an il y
a une décennie à peine ce constat d'une
tolérance interne au ministère de
l'Intérieur pour les policiers violents
s'accompagne d'une grande opacité
relative au nombre proprement dit de ses
violences policières puisqu'elles ne
sont pas centralisées au niveau de
l'IGPN
de fait l'IGPN et l'iggn ne traite que
10% des enquêtes judiciaires en visant
leur fonctionnaires le reste est traité
par des cellules de déontologie placées
auprès des DDSP en 2021
836 personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique ont été mises en cause dans une
affaire de violence volontaire parmi eux
cinq fonctionnaires sur 6 sont bénéficié
d'un classement sans suite il bénéficie
donc deux fois plus du classement sans
suite que la population générale alors
pourtant que leur statut constitue une
circonstance aggravate vente en cas de
violence et non une circonstance
atténuante comme la pratique nous le
montre
madame monsieur comment expliquez-vous
que les volumes de sanctions appliqués
soient en baisse quand les plaintes pour
violence policière explosent et pourquoi
vous inspections ne s'assurent-elles pas
de diminuer cette impunité qui a
alimenté
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la Directrice merci mon général pour
votre présentation éclairant la
déontologie l'exemplarité de nos forces
de l'or dont vos services sont les
gardiens la situation que vient de vivre
notre pays sur tout son territoire
l'attaque des symboles de la république
des locaux de forces de sécurité de nos
institutions d'élus la destruction
massive de bien public les pillages de
commerce ne peut être légitimés dans un
état de droit aucun drame ne peut
justifier un tel déferlement de violence
qui a plongé notre société dans la
sidération et dans une profonde colère
de sources gouvernementales depuis le
début des violences 42000 agents des
forces de l'ordre ont été mobilisées
3651 personnes ont été interpellées dont
1366 à Paris en région parisienne vos
services ont été saisis de 10 enquêtes
pendant les émeutes alors que l'IGPN
seul avait été saisi de 59 enquêtes
pendant la longue mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites
ce sont bien évidemment 10 de trop mais
rapportés au nombre important
d'interpellations le ratio est faible et
en baisse ce qui démontre que nos
policiers nos gendarmes sont globalement
soucieux de l'emploi légitime de la
force pouvez-vous nous confirmer ce
chiffre de 10
face à la complexité du rétablissement
de l'ordre du fait de l'extrême violence
constatée de certains individus
pouvez-vous de plus nous éclairer sur
les méthodes d'investigation de vos
services afin d'apporter des éléments de
preuves quant à la conformité à la loi
de l'usage de la force et quant à la
proportionnalité des réponses apportées
estimez-vous que les moyens dont vous
disposez sont suffisants je vous
remercie
monsieur run Malan
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice en général vous avez
insisté sur votre travail d'évaluation
de l'accueil au public vous savez la
grande cause du quinquennat précédent et
de ce quinquennat sur reste plus que
jamais d'actualité sur la question des
violences intrafes familiales et nous
devons continuer ce combat en 2021 ce ne
sont pas moins de 120
120000 victimes de violences conjugales
qui ont été prises en charge
judiciairement par les unités de
gendarmerie et de police donc les
gendarmes les policiers sont parmi les
premiers sur le terrain à protéger
écouter et le cas échéant enregistrer
les plans les plans de ces victimes de
violences conjugales il doit savoir et
doivent pouvoir les accueillir au mieux
elle ne doivent plus évidemment recourir
ce risque de victimisation secondaire en
ne se sentant pas écouté ni entendu par
les forces de l'ordre
cette nécessité a été mise en lumière
par les Grenelles contre les violences
conjugales et ce sont donc depuis 90 000
gendarmes et policiers qui ont été
formés à l'accueil de ses victimes et je
tiens à saluer le travail en particulier
de la gendarmerie de Quimperlé qui fait
un travail remarquable sur ce sujet vos
deux inspections générales et tout à
fait quand il y a du bon travail il faut
le signaler vos deux inspections
générales ont publié pour la première
fois en 2022 un audit sur l'accueil de
ces violences de violence sur ces sur
l'accueil de ces victimes de violences
conjugales pardon et ils ont permis de
constater qu'ils s'étaient amélioré le
deuxième rapport d'audit publié en juin
cette année par l'iggn permet de faire
le même compte stop toutefois toutefois
cette qualité d'accueil n'est pas sans
certaines carences qu'il est
indispensable de combler dans votre
rapport de 2022 publié en juin vous
pointez ainsi le manque d'accompagnement
social et le faible taux de contact avec
les associations d'aide aux victimes 62%
des personnes sollicitées ont ainsi
signalé l'absence de la prise de contact
la question est donc la suivante quelle
mesure concrète permettront la
gendarmerie de combler ce manque et je
doute pas que l'IGPN publiera elle aussi
son rapport d'audit pour 2022 aussi
j'aimerais savoir si vous faites le même
constat du manque d'accompagnement
social et du faible
madame Marietta karamani
15 secondes de plus c'est largement plus
que vos collègues monsieur
le Président merci aussi de cette de
cette audition ce matin très intéressant
je vous remercie tous les deux de
vos interventions moi je voulais au nom
de notre groupe et avec mes collègues
porter quelques questions et d'abord
en général les rapports de l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
analyse quantitativement et
qualitativement la déontologie des
comportements
anormaux et spéciaux si vous me
permettez l'expression donc je
souhaiterais savoir comment est organisé
donc la déontologie existe-t-il un
organe qui collégial avec des
personnalités extérieures et si Eli GGN
s'inspire d'exemples étrangers d'autres
par exemple
IG et des pays européens par exemple
pour améliorer son fonctionnement Madame
la Directrice les rapports de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale distingue procédures
administratives et judiciaire et insiste
au moins dans le rapport de 2021 qui
présente le comité d'évaluation de la de
la déontologie de la police nationale et
annonce la relance
le même rapport insiste sur l'audit
interne et l'autocontrôle alors
pouvez-vous nous parler un petit peu de
dans quelques mots quel est le bilan de
cette relance que vous avez suivi enfin
pouvez-vous nous dire tous les deux
quelle relation vous avez avec
l'élaboratoires de recherche publique
universitaire qui travaille sur la
sécurité qui travaillent sur les
méthodes de maintien de la sécurité
publique et de l'ordre public et quel
bilan en tirez-vous merci
Philippe Pradal
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice mon Général chers collègues
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
de votre présence en commission ce matin
et de vos propos introductifs et je
remercie également le président d'avoir
sur organisé cette audition conjointe
qui permet d'éclairer l'action des
forces de sécurité intérieure et de
permettre le contrôle que que nous
devons assurer je voulais également
m'associer aux propos qui ont été tenus
à la fois sur la qualité du travail des
forces de sécurité sur le nécessaire
contrôle et le niveau d'exigence que
vous portez pour que cette action
s'inscrive dans le respect des principes
républicains à la suite de beaucoup je
m'interroge sur l'évolution de la place
et du rôle des forces de sécurité dans
notre société les espaces de leur action
se sont considérablement étendus je
pense ici notamment aux réseaux sociaux
au développement de la criminalité en
ligne en outre leur mission
structurellement mutée alors que jusque
dans les années 70 les forces de
sécurité intérieure c'était avant tout
préoccupé de sécurité nationale d'ordre
public et de grands banditisme c'est
aperçu que la sécurité quotidienne des
Français pouvait donner l'impression
d'avoir été négligé aussi convenait de
s'attaquer à la petite et moyenne
délinquance ainsi qu'au sentiment
d'insécurité on rend parallèle le
rapport à l'autorité c'est lentement
d'élite et je constate notamment dans ma
circonscription mais comme ailleurs une
multiplication des infractions et des
incivilités du quotidien vite cassé tag
bagarre urbaine et tous les felliers au
trafic de stupéfiants le civisme élément
cardinal de notre vie en société de
notre nation et de notre République se
perd les forces de sécurité intérieure
sont ainsi quotidiennement amenées à
gérer ce type de troubles à l'ordre
public parfois éloigné de ce qui
constitué un temps le cœur de leur
mission à ce titre votre perception et
votre retour m'intéresse le maintien
d'un très haut niveau d'exigence pour
les forces de sécurité qui est
évidemment souhaitable dans leur action
se heurte-t-il à la baisse du sentiment
de civisme dans la population comment
dans le cas de vos fonctions pensez vous
pouvoir accompagner les forces de
sécurité dans leur mission face aux
nouvelles formes de délinquance et à
l'évolution des attitudes à l'égard des
forces de sécurité je vous remercie
merci Madame Sandra rogol
bonjour merci merci surtout pour cet
exercice de transparence qui est
toujours fort utile donc merci Monsieur
le Directeur merci Madame la Directrice
c'est dommage parce qu'un essayant de
faire un comparatif de deux maisons si
proches et pourtant si différente j'ai
plus noté que malheureusement les
chiffres 2022 de l'IGPN n'était pas
encore disponible donc je vais me
contenter de poser des questions sur
l'année 2021 c'est fort dommage
d'ailleurs parce que je dois remarquer
que côté
iggène vous m'avez beaucoup fait sourire
avec un hangar qui ne manquait pas de
sel pour spécifier que dans la
gendarmerie il n'y a pas eu un seul mort
en cas de refus de notre tempéré sur
toute l'année 2022 j'avoue que le maître
en exergue sur votre petit encart bleu
était particulièrement dans les jours
qui nous occupent quelque chose qui m'a
attiré donc ce qu'on doit faire
aujourd'hui c'est critiquer pour avoir
des moyens d'améliorer donc je vais
essayer d'être rapide avec des questions
précises sur qu'est-ce que chiffres qui
m'ont intéressé donc j'aimerais avoir
vos deux retour sur certains chiffres le
nombre de morts évidemment mes collègues
en ont parlé disons côté 37 de l'autre
c'est une constante enfin c'est 2021
mais c'est une constante que l'on peut
noter à travers le temps et qui
malheureusement augmente mais ça
augmente aussi du côté des agents le
nombre de fusils 22 dans la gendarmerie
46 dans la police là encore on voit la
même disproportion et je note que côté
igpn il y a tout envolé sur les suicides
à l'intérieur de l'institution qui
n'existe pas côté gendarmerie si on
prend un peu de recul et la période
2009-2020 on constate que les sanctions
pour violence côté police s'écroule à
partir de 2017 alors que les sanctions
pour problème avec sa hiérarchie eux
augmentent ce qui n'est pas du tout en
corrélation avec les saisies qui sont
faites sur la plateforme de signalement
qui elle double contre 2017 et 2021 il y
a une petite incohérence sur lesquels
sur laquelle j'aimerais bien avoir votre
avis alors effectivement il y a une
hausse globale des chiffres des deux
côtés mais qui côté police est un peu
supérieur merci
je vous propose de répondre à cette
première série de questions pas vous
étiez pas inscrit même si il faut vous
inscrire alors allez-y posez votre
question et ensuite on fera la réponse
merci Madame la Directrice Monsieur le
Directeur l'impartialité et
l'indépendance ce sont évidemment des
conditions
nécessaires indispensables pour ceux et
celles qui contrôlent l'action de ce et
celle qui emploie la force publique il y
a des exigences importantes qui doivent
entourer le contrôle de l'action des
forces de l'ordre je pense à la
pertinence et à la diligence des
enquêtes c'est à dire la collecte
effective et efficace des preuves utile
identification et la sanction des
auteurs alors forcément il y a des
collègues qui ont dit on parle toujours
de certaines affaires et pas d'autres en
même temps
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y en a quand
même très très peu où il y a des
sanctions effectives mais je me dis
est-ce que c'est principe ils sont
respectés quand l'IGPN par exemple
décide de ne pas saisir l'enregistrement
de la radio du policier qui a tiré sur
Zineb Redouane il y a aussi l'exigence
de l'Association des victimes est-ce que
ce principe il est respecté quand une
jeune de 19 ans qui a gardé des
séquelles au cerveau après un passage à
tabac par des policiers à essuyer deux
refus de dépôt de plainte il y a le
contrôle public et la transparence
est-ce que c'est principe sont respectés
quand je dois m'appuyer sur les données
de 2019 pour dire que seuls 0,4 % des
signalements ont donné lieu à des
sanctions pour faute grave dans votre
rapport d'activité le précédent vous
écriviez que l'ambition première de les
GPN était de valoriser l'institution et
ses agents je trouve cet aveu étrange il
pointe un problème qui surplombe à mon
sens l'ensemble de notre de notre propos
et qui parle quelque part de l'impunité
qui est ressenti par beaucoup de nos
concitoyens et puis il y a toute cette
question évidemment liée au racisme
quand vous êtes un homme noir arabe ou
supposé c'est 20 fois plus de risques de
se faire contrôler pensez-vous
réellement que les testings peuvent
subir suffire à y faire face pensez-vous
pour gagner en indépendance et en
impartialité que il ne faudrait pas que
les fonctionnaires de les GPN ne
puissent ensuite pas retourner en
mission en service merci et bien donc
pour cette première série de questions
je vous propose de répondre comme vous
voulez d'abord
merci merci
moi je vous confirme qu'il n'y a pas
d'impunité pour les forces de l'ordre
que les sanctions sont effectives que
les contrôles sont extrêmement ciblés et
je recevais je réponds à deux questions
un jour ce verre récemment un chercheur
Jacques de Maillard que vous connaissez
tous puisque je vous dis que je
travaille avec beaucoup de chercheurs
enfin quatre ou cinq que vous connaissez
aussi et Jacques de Maillard ma démarche
pour faire un travail notamment sur les
caméras piétons et voir qu'est-ce qui
était
utile et comment on pouvait travailler
avec des drones et tout ça et l'utilité
des images et je lui disais mais en 2020
je crois que j'étais passé justement sur
une question pour une
un travail qu'on faisait sur le racisme
je répondais que aujourd'hui l'image est
devenue l'ADN qu'on connaissions il y a
20-30 ans qui était une révolution dans
la police judiciaire et aujourd'hui
c'est l'image l'IPA je qui prévaut qui
donne des orientations etc alors moi je
ne propose pas d'évolution législatives
je trouve qu'il y a un emballement que
tout est prévu pratiquement et que il
faut arrêter de vouloir réformer un
permanence le code pénal il faudrait
plutôt réfléchir à le simplifier et
arrêtons de multiplier les lois etc et
appliquant ce qui existe et aujourd'hui
je pense que les magistrats ont tout
dans le code pénal et le code de
procédure pénale prévoit ainsi de choses
mais par pitié veillez aussi à ne pas
compliquer l'action des enquêteurs alors
le rythme de travail le rythme travail
moi je peux vous dire que un gendarmerie
on a parfois un rythmé levé en ce moment
vous le savez mais je n'ai jamais jamais
je le dis bien et même dans des moments
très difficiles de ma vie
ressenti une une et à limite je vous
dirais que nous les gendarmes on est là
pour ça quoi on est un statut militaire
on compte pas notre temps de travail
maintenant on le on le limite c'est
limité c'est vous qui l'avez décidé
l'Europe aussi à orienter etc mais quand
il faut y aller il faut y aller et vous
l'avez vu récemment avec des chiffres
que j'ai là on est capable de monter un
nombre on est capable de venir comme
récemment avait plus de 5000 gendarmes
en zone police parce que nécessité fait
loi pour protéger les bâtiments
notamment voilà alors vous parliez des
réservistes des réservistes aujourd'hui
on est plus de 34000 réserves Saint-Jean
d'armurerie je vous peux vous dire que
en 40 ans de métiers puisque j'ai 60 ans
passés ça fait 40 ans que je sers j'ai
vu grandir et
évoluer cette réserve opérationnelle de
la gendarme varie une façon remarquable
d'une façon remarquable parce que ils
sont à proximité ils sont faciles à
employer et aujourd'hui on ne serait pas
faire le tour de France sans les
réserves sans les réserviste on sait pas
faire tourner le sourd de France on sait
pas monté en capacité sans ces 30 ans 32
000 réservistes opérationnels que nous
avons et avec des ambitions de monter
plus de réservistes mais avec des
difficultés qui sont vieilles
identifiées alors
la question portée sur comment améliorer
comment améliorer la ruralité pour la
gendarmerie alors je veux quand même
vous rappeler que la majorité des
gendarmes servent en zone périurbaine en
zone et pas tous à Cugnaux autour de
Toulouse ou autre mais le rural trop
fort il y en a bien sûr à peu près 15%
de la gendarmerie mais c'est très faible
c'est très faible et ce n'est pas un
problème mais il faut tenir il faut être
incapacité d'agir quand vous appelle ce
cours ou quand il y a le petit Émile qui
disparaît vous êtes tous émus on est on
doit être en capacité de se mobiliser
donc ne soyez pas inquiet il n'y aura
pas de territoire abandonnés pour les
Jeux Olympiques il y a déjà des choses
de prévues d'ailleurs le ministre
c'était avait évoqué il y aura une
suspension des ondes de compétences et
des gendarmes vous le savez auront
vocation à couvrir certaines zones
polices etc
donc l'amélioration des conditions de
travail je pense que à travers le CFMG
l'entreprise structure de concertation
et le DGGN est très attentif nous avons
une dynamique une dynamique qui fait que
l'État doit conserver une gendarmerie
sereine et une gendarmerie efficace pour
son concitoyen une gendarmerie aussi
sereine si une gendarmerie avait des
gendarmes à l'écoute et proche de leur
concitoyens rappelez-vous ce qui se
passait j'étais sur le terrain j'étais à
Rennes je commandais la zone ouest au
moment des gilets jaunes où nous avions
des gendarmes qui étaient au contact sur
les ronds-points avec des gens qui
connaissaient des gens qui connaissaient
bien sûr alors
vous avez vu que vous nous dit que il y
a eu 10 enquêtes judiciaires qui ont été
ouvertes récemment nous en avons une
pour la gendarmerie sur les 10 une c'est
un tir de LBD à Tours en zone police ou
les gendarmes sont intervenus pour
protéger
euh pour protéger un établissement il y
a eu un tir de LBD il y a une personne
qui a perdu un œil et donc et ben il y a
il y a une enquête et croyez bien que
l'enquête là aussi se déroule sous la
responsabilité du procureur de la
République et bien sûr nous imitons les
moyennes les moyens nécessaires alors
l'accueil du public la queue du public
soyez
soyez sûr que c'est une de mes
préoccupations et j'en veux pour preuve
comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on
a réellement une attention et pas
uniquement pour les victimes de vif
comme ça a été évoquée etc sachez que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que nous
produisions des kits pédagogiques et
bien le dernier kit pédagogique c'est
sur l'accueil des victimes avec une
petite vidéo de 4 minutes et avec un
PowerPoint qui descend dans les unités
et le commandant de brigade va rappeler
vous voyez avec des exemples hyper
concrets je vous souligne que nous
n'avons rien inventé dans les deux cas
on les a enrichis mais rien inventé ou
une jeune femme vient pour déposer
plainte et elle n'est pas reçue parce
que c'est 12h30 et le gendarme était
parti se restaurer tout cela tout cela
est bien marqué et on cherche à
sensibiliser je le dis bien et le mot
que j'aime bien c'est concrètement pour
éviter qu'il y ait des fautes voilà
dans les
dans les analyses de comportement les
analyses de comportement
il n'y a pas chez nous de d'organes
collégial avec des regards externes mais
j'ai souhaité comme je vous l'ai dit
échanger avec les chercheurs c'était une
un souhait j'ai échangé avec Jacques de
Maillard Matthieu zagrowski Sébastien
rocher etc qui conduisent des études et
qui le dernier c'est Christian Moana qui
est qui était il y a deux mois de mois à
l'iggn et qui interviewait les
personnels du bej pour savoir comment
des conditions des enquêteurs quel était
leur indépendance tout ça et il fait une
comparaison avec quatre pays vous voyez
quatre pays donc nous n'avons pas de de
laboratoire de recherche
nous avons lancéogène et nous avons
cette activité mais bien sûr nous avons
engagé cette dynamique d'échange
d'échange qui nous permet aussi de nous
sensibiliser tout à l'heure vous parliez
des refus d'obtempérer alors je m'étais
dans rapport d'activité qui est je la
dis paru il y a un mois donc bien avant
le décès Noël je disais que nous
n'avions aucun mort lié à l'action de
gendarme même si je vous rappelle que
nous avons eu 30 tirs de gendarmes pour
immobiliser du véhicule notamment sur
les roues mais ces 32 tir je le dis sont
pratiquement inutiles et d'ailleurs les
Allemands ne tirent pas sur les
véhicules parce que vous n'arrêtez pas
un véhicule avec une arme à feu quand
vous êtes quand vous êtes en danger
quand on fonce sur vous que
l'obligation de d'essayer de de
travailler dans la profondeur et pour
donc vous voyez que il y a toute une
démarche pédagogique et le travail que
j'ai que j'initie avec mes personnels et
vous avez vu ils sont peu les 117 et B
quand nous avons des résultats quand
nous avons des retours quand vous avons
une baisse de l'adversité quand nous
avons une baisse des tirs quand vous
n'avons une baisse du nombre de saisines
grave une saisie ne pour défaire de
racisme une saisie ne pour des
fédérations en 2022 et bien nous en
sommes je le dis
légitimement fier il n'y a pas lieu
d'être pas fier de certains résultats
alors
la question une autre question posée sur
la place et le rôle des forces de
sécurité avec les réseaux sociaux les
trafics le civisme qui part et bien je
suis d'accord avec vous je vois une
perte du civisme et
qui est au contact de la misère sociale
quand tout est fermé quand tout est
fermé et bien il y a la police la
gendarmerie et nous n'oublions pas les
hôpitaux les
urgences où les gens arrivent et je vous
assure ces gens-là ces gens-là
abélissent et ils sont parfois en
difficulté ils sont parfois par rapport
à des gens qui sont extrêmement violents
et moi je ça m'est donné l'occasion
devant cette oppression de nationale je
tiens à le rendre hommage merci
c'est le président
tout d'abord en réponse à plusieurs
interrogations le rapport annuel rendant
compte de l'activité 2022 de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale sera dans les tous prochains
jours mis en ligne auquel il sera annexé
le rapport annuel relatif à l'accueil
des victimes dans les services de police
les contrôlinopinés dont nous faisions
état précédemment vous trouverez un
certain nombre de chiffres ce qui ne
m'empêchera pas en réponse à plusieurs
de vos questions de dévoiler des
éléments de ce de ce rapport
en premier lieu sur les moyens dont on
dispose
les moyens dont on dispose j'ai évoqué
dans mon propos liminaire le nombre
d'enquêteurs n'ont pas pour donner un
chiffre inutile mais pour simplement
indiquer que ce nombre d'enquêteurs
est compétent sur une zone géographique
très large et c'est la raison pour
laquelle par définition l'IGPN ne peut
pas être saisie en réponse à une
interrogation monsieur le député ne peut
pas être saisi de l'ensemble des faits
impliquant les fonctionnaires de police
raison pour laquelle nous devons nous
féliciter de l'existence de cellules de
déontologie au sein des directions
territoriales comme comme vous
l'évoquiez
sur nos moyens légaux nous en disposons
sans nul doute l'inspection générale de
la police nationale et solidement ancré
il y a une modification que nous
pourrions porter qui est celle de la
modification de l'article 11-2 du code
de procédure pénale pour le dire
autrement cet article nous permet en
l'état du cadre légal en cas de
poursuite à savoir renvoi de un tribunal
correctionnel par exemple ou de mise en
examen de pouvoir solliciter de
l'autorité judiciaire des éléments de la
procédure judiciaire aux fins de les
mettre dans l'enquête administrative
nous souhaiterions un élargissement de
ces dispositions pour que on puisse
disposer de façon plus large de ces
éléments particulièrement importants
dans le cadre des enquêtes
administratives puisque dans le cadre
des enquêtes administratives nous avons
des moyens et c'est tout à fait normal
limité nous n'avons pas moyen de
contraintes nous n'avons pas de moyens
d'investigation qui seraient intrusif
mais ces enquêtes administratives et en
réponse là aussi à une interpellation
que j'ai pu avoir nous nous devons de
les ouvrir dans un temps extrêmement
rapide nous nous devons les mener avec
toute la rigueur qui s'impose dans le
devoir de réaction de l'administration
est importante les enquêtes judiciaires
j'ai pu l'évoquer nous les conduisons
sous l'autorité des magistrats
instructeurs les enquêtes
administratives outils du devoir de
réaction de l'administration égyptiens
nous nous devons de les clôturer avec
toute la rigueur mais aussi la célérité
qui s'impose pour permettre ensuite à
l'administration et encore une fois
j'insiste nous n'avons qu'un pouvoir de
proposition de sanction et non pas de
prononcer de sanction donc c'est ensuite
à l'administration de prononcer des
sanctions au regard des manquements que
nous pouvons relever dans nos enquêtes
administratives
sur les moyens techniques caméras
piétons drone notamment nous ne pouvons
que nous féliciter de se renforcement de
l'image l'image est fondamentale dans
les enquêtes vous pouvez tous le
constater j'insiste néanmoins sur un
point l'image ne peut pas être l'alpha
et l'oméga d'une procédure que ce soit
une procédure administrative ou une
procédure judiciaire il est trop facile
de se dire que le simple visionnage
d'une image nous permet de comprendre
les circonstances de la commission des
faits les raisons pour lesquelles le
policier a ingé ainsi et donc ce serait
contraire au travail de tout bonne
enquêteur d'enquêter à charge à des
charges que de se contenter d'image
cependant concernant le exemple précis
des caméras piétons je peux noter deux
choses d'une part que c'est un aliment
essentiel en termes de preuve et que
nous n'avons de cesse dans notre domaine
de compétences que de rappeler aux
policiers la nécessité d'activer les
caméras piétons tant c'est un élément de
preuve important et deuxième élément que
je tiens à souligner en termes de
désescalade dans la relation du policier
avec le citoyen c'est un élément
également qui nous semble
particulièrement révélateur
vous avez pu évoquer la difficulté à
laquelle les policiers sont confrontés
les uns et les autres je l'ai indiqué
l'IGPN n'est pas déconnecté de la
réalité du terrain très clairement elle
ne l'est pas pour autant en toute
connaissance de cause y compris des
difficultés particulières auxquelles
sont confrontées les policiers de d'une
adversité réelle à laquelle ils peuvent
se retrouver confrontés nous nous devons
de rappeler quand toutes circonstances
et j'insiste en toute circonstances le
devoir d'exemplarité du par chacun des
policiers doit être rempli
sur la problématique puisque par le
terme de refus d'obtempérer elle a pu
être évoqué des tirs sur les véhicules
en mouvement
les tirs sur les véhicules en mouvement
c'est un sujet depuis que je suis
alligpn et mes équipes pourraient en
témoigner qui ne cessent de me
préoccuper tant de nous nous devons pour
l'institution pour la société de
réfléchir à ce sujet dans quelles
conditions les policiers sont-ils amenés
à tirés pour quelle raison comment les
former comment tirer des enseignements
des différentes procédures parce que en
2022 nous avons eu 13 morts liés à des
tirs sur des véhicules en mouvement et
que nécessairement ça interroge ce
chiffre de 13 morts doit être mis au
regard d'éléments et que je veux ici
rappeler tant on entend tout et son
contraire sur une évolution qui serait
croissante sur les tirs sur les
véhicules en mouvement en 2021 157 sur
tir sur des véhicules en mouvement avec
l'arme individuel en 2022 138 tirs sur
des véhicules en mouvement avec l'armée
individuelle
ces chiffres sont à mettre au regard
parce que je me dois d'être complète de
deux morts en 2021 et de 13 morts je
l'ai évoqué en 2022
l'article
435-1 du code de la sécurité intérieure
issue de la loi de février 2017 tant
commenté ces derniers temps
prescrit un régime très strict et très
précis pour les policiers et pour les
gendarmes d'ailleurs puisque ce texte
qui est un texte spécial si j'ose dire
de la légitime défense pour les
policiers et les gendarmes indique que
il ne peut être fait
usage de l'arme qu'en cas d'absolu
nécessité et de strict proportionnalité
et je tiens ici à le à le souligner
autre élément sur
l'impartialité et l'indépendance je
pense que nous n'avons de cesse de le
démontrer nos enquêtes administratives
quand nous sommes saisis de procédures
judiciaires nous les ouvrons
systématiquement des enquêtes
administratives prédisciplinaires
nous enquêtons dans le cas des enquêtes
judiciaires nous nous devons de récolter
des preuves que nous transmettons à
l'autorité judiciaire que ce soit dans
le cas des enquêtes administratives ou
des enquêtes prédisciplinaires l'IGPN
n'a pas le pouvoir ni de prononcer des
peines et c'est heureux ni de prononcer
des sanctions et c'est ainsi que
fonctionne notre institution
par rapport à ici encore une évocation
du député Coulommes notamment sur
l'usage du lanceur de balle de défense
vous verrez dans le rapport annuel 2022
que nous sommes sur des chiffres
constants
sur le nombre de procédures judiciaires
qui ont pu être ouvertes dans la suite
des émeutes liés au fait dramatique à
Nanterre sur le décès du jeune Naël qui
a pu être évoqué
je ne commenterai évidemment absolument
pas ni le nombre ni la nature des
saisines je peux simplement vous
indiquer que le nombre de 10 enquêtes
judiciaires qui avaient pu vous être
communiquer et par essence si j'ose dire
caduque puisque il évolue et que nous
avons aujourd'hui 21 procédures
judiciaires en cours étant précisé que
sur les 21 à l'instar de ce que j'avais
pu indiquer au moment du décompte qui
avait été fait sur les procédures
ouvertes en lien avec la miniatation des
retraites sont de gravité et de nature
très différentes les unes d'entre elles
donc ce simple chiffre n'est à mon sens
révélateur et je ne peux pas aller au
bla pour des raisons de protection du
secret de l'enquête et des
investigations en cours
sur le comité d'évaluation des la
déontologie de la police nationale que
la députée carrément dit a rappelé nos
travaux se sont concentrés sur les
contrôles d'identité et je remettrai
à l'automne au plus tard un rapport
dédié sur cette réflexion que nous avons
menée en lien avec le contrôle
d'identité quel usage quelle efficacité
et encore une fois je souligne la
capacité de l'institution en lien avec
les membres du comité d'évaluation que
j'ai pu énumérer dans le cadre de mon
propos liminaire a interrogé cette
pratique qui est au cœur de la relation
police population
comme l'indiqué le général Pidou nos
relations avec l'extérieur elles sont
constantes avec les chercheurs je vais
pas reprendre ce qu'a dit le général
Pidou je ne redirai que la même chose
bien évidemment que nous ouvrons nos
portes aux universitaires et c'est
essentiel pour participer à cette
réflexion commune mais en interne à
l'inspection parce qu'une inspection par
essence doit en permanence interroger
réinterroger les pratiques nous sommes
en questionnement permanent et bien
avant l'effet dramatique de Nanterre
notamment sur la problématique de
l'usage des armes nous avions mené en
interne une réflexion et pour tenter de
dégager des pistes
enfin sur la problématique des suicides
qui a été évoqué et justement évoquée à
l'Inspection générale de la police
nationale il y a un travail très fin
pour chaque suicide que déplore la
police nationale pour comprendre les
raisons et infini déterminé s'il y a ou
non une imputabilité au service
voilà rapidement en réponse à vos
questions qui sont très denses donc dans
le temps qui nous est imparti il est
compliqué d'y répondre avec
l'exhaustivité qui pourrait être
attendue
alors d'abord je rappelle que la
commission des lois se verra proposer
par le biais de son bureau de commission
une mission d'évaluation de la loi de
2007 sur le l'usage des armes pour les
refus d'obtempérer ce sera à la rentrée
en septembre prochain j'ai encore 5 15
cris pour des questions et ensuite nous
devrons nous libérer il y a pas de deux
fois de questions madame rigole donc je
décide les cinq inscrits c'est Monsieur
Boudier monsieur Rambaud madame Diaz
Monsieur bobry et Madame bobonneau et
ensuite on répondra monsieur Boudier
oui merci monsieur le président
quelques quelques questions deux plus
précisément et je veux quand même dire à
mon collègue notre collègue
Jean-François Coulogne que nous avons
auditionné hier la Défenseur des droits
dans le cadre de la commission d'enquête
sur les groupes muscules violents et ces
propos étaient loin d'être aussi
caricaturaux y compris d'ailleurs sur la
question des LBD où elle soulignait que
ces derniers mois ces derniers mois y
compris la séquence récente les
réclamations visant les LBD avec
significativement baissé je vous invite
à lire le compte-rendu de cette audition
deux questions par conséquent la
première en général Madame la Directrice
la première concerne la question des
forces des armes intermédiaires
j'en parlais à l'instant concernant les
LBD
le nombre de situations dont vous avez
été saisies dans chacune de vos
inspections concernant l'usage des
forces intermédiaires ce que vous avez
des éléments à nous communiquer sur
cette aspect puis les observations qui
sont les vôtres éventuellement sur
ce débat aujourd'hui binaire entre ceux
qui considèrent qu'il faut augmenter
considérablement les moyens
intermédiaires
et puis celles et ceux qui considèrent
qu'il faut les supprimer totalement
comment vous situer votre analyse au
sein de vos deux inspections deuxième
question en général vous avez noté à
juste titre qu'il y a plusieurs types de
contrôle il y a à la fois le contrôle
par les pairs hiérarchiques il y a le
contrôle interne ce sont les inspections
il y a le contrôle externe c'est la
Défenseur des droits et ça n'est que la
Défenseur des droits
nous avons néanmoins créé dans le cadre
de la loi d'orientation de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur je dois le
dire d'ailleurs en coordination complète
avec notre collègue Cécile Anto Mayer un
collège de déontologie du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui doit être présidé par
une personnalité qui n'est pas issue du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est un
élément de négociation d'ailleurs assez
fin avec bobo où en est-on et surtout
avez-vous été associés à la fois la
rédaction des textes de concernant et à
sa composition je vous remercie monsieur
Stéphane Rambaud
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice mon général en tant que chef
de l'IGPN et chef de l'iggn je reconnais
volontiers la difficulté votre de votre
tâche le chiffre de plus de 4300
gendarmes blessés cité par vous mon
Général était différent
je vous remercie et au nom du groupe
rassemblement national de nous avoir
éclairé sur l'état de vos travaux en
cours en démocratie il est important que
des cordes de contrôle puissent
s'assurer que les règles d'usage de la
force soit respectés et que des enquêtes
puissent être diligentées lorsque
lorsque des soupçons d'actes contraires
à la loi ou au code de déontologie se
font jour la police et la gendarmerie
nationale
sanctionne sévèrement les dérives et
c'est une bonne chose cependant fort de
mon expérience de 37 ans en tant que
commissaire de police je sais combien le
travail sur le terrain est difficile de
faire aussi face aux événements surtout
quand ils sont de nature aussi violente
que ce que nous venons de traverser
récemment
permettez-moi de rendre ici hommage
comme l'immense majorité de nos
concitoyens à nos policiers à nos
gendarmes à nos sapeurs-pompiers qui ont
fait preuve d'un courage exceptionnel
face à l'adversité à la violence aveugle
de la rue plus de 700 personnels des
forces de l'ordre ont été blessées ces
derniers jours c'est un très lourd tribu
que rien ne saurait excusé ces éléments
ne peuvent être ignorés c'est pourquoi
je vous demande de bien vouloir nous
expliquer comment à chaud au plus proche
des événements les enquêtes que vous
menez sont à même de pouvoir prendre
suffisamment de distance pour rester
impartial et c'est très important à même
pour les personnes mises en cause qu'ils
soient policiers ou gendarmes
l'assurance d'un examen respectant au
mieux la présomption d'innocence Daniel
le Bono
merci Madame anitris général pour vos
exposés instructifs je voulais vous
interpeller Madame la Directrice sur la
problématique de l'indépendance de
l'IGPN qui est un sujet qui
interpelle parce que
on ne peut pas qualifier du point de vue
de l'ombre observateur
cette inspection qu'on me véritablement
indépendante puisque selon l'article
premier du décret qu'il établit c'est un
service actif de la Direction Générale
de la Police or l'indépendance et
conceptualisée par l'absence de
suggestions suggestions hiérarchique et
de rapport avec le groupe professionnel
pourtant c'est bien le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui décide du budget de
votre institution la direction est
nommée par le directeur général de la
police qu'elle est censée contrôler
lui-même est nommée par l'exécutif de
plus
la direction générale de la police peut
révoquer votre votre propre direction
les enquêteurs et enquêteries sont
nommés par la Direction Générale de la
Police
alors même que ça peut parfois
conditionné leur carrière future et
non seulement cela mais quand on regarde
du point de vue y compris des des
modèles étrangers il y a plutôt une
pratique de modèles d'inspection Miss
mixte ou véritable
véritablement indépendante je pense à
l'exemple du Royaume-Uni ou pour des
affaires graves l'office est indépendant
du comportement policier peut s'auto
saisir il est véritablement indépendant
de l'exécutif notamment parce qu'il a
son propre budget avec des enquêteurs
qui ne sont pas rattachés à un service
actif et des directeurs qui ne sont pas
policiers vous êtes ancien magistrates
mais ce n'est pas une
ce n'est pas une règle et dans la
majorité des cas pour pour l'IGPN au
Damart l'autorité indépendante pour les
plaintes à l'encontre de la police est
diriger par un bureau avec un ou une
juge des avocats des professeurs des
professeurs de jurisprudence il y a
également l'exemple du Québec vous
indiquez qu'il y a une réflexion sur
l'institution admet la question de
l'indépendance est ce est-ce que c'est
un sujet sur lequel vous avez
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice mon général en préambule de
mon propos je voudrais comme mes
collègues du groupe rassemblement
national salué le travail des policiers
et des gendarmes qui œuvrent chaque jour
à la protection de nos citoyens malgré
les critiques récurrentes et souvent
caricaturales d'une minorité bruyante et
agissante je voudrais évoquer le rapport
publié il y a deux jours par la Ligue
des droits de l'Homme au sujet des
événements survenus à Sainte Soline mon
sentiment sur ce rapport c'est qu'il
tente de réécrire l'histoire en faisant
passer les gendarmes pour des guerriers
factieux sur armés prêts à s'acharner
violemment sur de gentils manifestants
écologistes et pacifiques et n'ayant
commis aucune infraction ni bravé aucune
interdiction ces retours ont été
formulés par des individus appelés
observateurs alors sujet je souhaite
mettre en lumière une liste non
exhaustive d'informations pour le moins
surprenante carence en matière de
formation absence d'harmonisation sur la
formation à l'échelle nationale
apparemment obligation d'une signature
d'une charte d'engagement mais
curieusement cette charte n'est pas
disponible que sur leur site internet en
matière de transparence on repassera et
enfin absence de contrôle de ces
observateurs via par exemple une
homologation ou une certification malgré
ces manquements ces observateurs qu'on
peut qualifier d'autoproclamer bénéficie
d'une portée médiatique inversement
proportionnelle à leur partialité qui
sert les discours anti-flics de ceux qui
passent leur temps à crier ou à
s'afficher aux côtés de ceux qui crient
tout le monde déteste la police ainsi
alors que vous disposez à l'iggn de 117
agents assermentés et dont la légitimité
et l'exemplarité ne saurait être remise
en cause je voudrais vous demander
comment vous percevez ce genre de
rapport en matière d'impact premièrement
sur le moral des forces de l'ordre et
dans un second temps en matière
d'aggravation et d'augmentation des
violences commises à l'encontre des
forces de l'ordre qui comme vous l'avez
rappelé mon général en ce qui concerne
les gendarmes ont doublé en 10 ans je
vous remercie
au sujet de la formation alors elle est
souvent critiquée et souvent par ceux
qui n'ont aucune idée du déroulement de
celle-ci que pensez-vous de la formation
actuellement dispensée aux élèves qu'ils
soient gardiens de la paix ou gendarmes
quelle évolution de la qualité de
celle-ci notez-vous et est-elle en
équation avec l'augmentation de la
défiance dont il font l'objet et en
parlant de défiance certains réclament
la mise en place de récépissé lors des
contrôles d'identité les 100 penser que
les personnes pourraient être contrôlées
du simple fait de leur faciès que
pensez-vous de cette proposition et je
terminerai par dire que la nomination de
magistrat au sein de vos services
respectifs ce qui devrait notamment
apparemment être le cas à l'éligène
prochainement
fait que les procès de l'entre-soi ne
sont pas du tout crédibles et je
rappelle et j'appelle de mes vœux cette
même ouverture de la part du ministère
de la Justice avec la nomination
pourquoi pas à la tête de l'inspection
générale de la justice d'un policier ou
d'un gendarme je vous remercie
merci vous avez observé d'ailleurs que à
l'École nationale de la magistrature
c'est une avocate qui est désormais à la
tête de cette école
général Madame la Directrice vous
l'aurez donc à l'ordre allez-y
en réponse
notamment
la députée au Bono et au député en beau
l'éthique de responsabilité et ancrée au
sein de l'inspection générale de la
police nationale nous avons une charte
qui repose sur trois valeurs
l'exemplarité l'objectivité et
l'expertise
vous pouvez la lire d'ores et déjà dans
le rapport annuel 2021 et je la remets
avec force dans le rapport annuel de
2022 cette éthique de responsabilité
elle emporte bien évidemment
conscience de la responsabilité très
lourde que nous avons en termes de
contrôle d'organes internes de la police
nationale alors oui l'inspection
générale de la police nationale et
une direction active de la police
nationale et j'ajouterai même que j'ai
deux chefs le directeur général de la
police nationale et le préfet de police
est-ce à dire que l'inspection générale
de la police nationale n'est pas
indépendante elle sait à dire que nous
n'avons pas de crédit sur le premier
point sur l'indépendance puisque c'est
là la question je l'ai dit je le répète
avec force les enquêtes administratives
prédisciplinaires personne mais
absolument personne ne guide notre plume
pour relever les manquements et pour
proposer des sanctions dans le cadre des
procédures judiciaires personne
absolument personne autre que l'autorité
judiciaire ne guide notre plume nos
guides nos missions pour faire en sorte
de parvenir à la manifestation de la
vérité alors si de dire que les crédits
des crédits d'ailleurs qui sont votés et
je vous en remercie par le Parlement et
avec une ventilation qui est faite dans
la loi si c'est de dire que nous ne
sommes pas indépendants et donc que il y
aurait par définition une défiance
vis-à-vis de notre action je vous invite
à venir voir les uns et les autres comme
le président de la commission des lois
et le député rudiges ont pu le faire la
façon dont les enquêteurs et travail et
encore une fois dire que nous le ferions
avec une partialité avec une absence de
conscience de la tâche qui nous incombe
serait faire une insulte vraiment à tous
les agents d'inspection générale de la
police nationale
autre problématique celle de la
formation celle de la formation qui est
essentielle et j'ai d'ailleurs conclu
mon propos introductif en disant que
c'était une action socle de l'inspection
parce que de même que nous nous devons
d'avoir une réflexion permanente en vue
de l'amélioration continue du service
public de la sécurité nous nous devons
de sécuriser le policier de terrain au
quotidien et cette sécurisation
pas par une formation
idoine aussi bien une formation très
pratico pratique facile sur quel est le
cadre légal pour simplifier un texte qui
part définition et complexe puisque la
loi prévoit les choses pour simplifier
c'est le sens des fiches que j'ai pu
évoquer de la maîtrise des risques très
pratiques au pratique c'est le sens de
nos échanges permanents avec la
direction centrale de la formation de la
police nationale pour faire que le
policier à qui on revient ensuite
reprocher des choses dans le cas d'une
enquête administrative ou dans le cas
d'une enquête judiciaire il soit formée
assez difficultés auxquelles il pourrait
être confronté
sur le sujet
du collège de déontologie du ministère
de l'Intérieur tel que prévu dans le
rapport annexé de la locmi que vous avez
adopté ce collège de déontologie du
ministère de l'Intérieur il prendra la
suite d'un collège de déontologie auquel
nous participions avec le général Pidou
qui rassemblait les référents
déontologues du ministère de l'Intérieur
et qui était présidé par un membre du
Conseil d'État le président Vigouroux en
l'occurrence en sa qualité de référent
déontologue du ministère de l'Intérieur
ce collège de déontologie par le rapport
annexé adopté dans la locmi à une
composition différente nous avons été
associés à la rédaction du texte et nous
attendons d'en connaître précisément de
manière individualisée les membres et
bien évidemment que nous nous tiendrons
à la disposition position des travaux de
ce de ce collège
tout autre sujet sans transition j'en
suis désolé pour répondre à votre
question monsieur le député Bourdieu
Bourdier pardon
les forces
les les
usages de force intermédiaires des armes
intermédiaires pardon
vous évoquez un débat binaire c'est
précisément l'écueil dans lequel tout
inspection ne doit pas tomber de débat
binaire il ne peut pas y en avoir de
conscience de la nécessité de ses forces
et des besoins
réels c'est une c'est une chose que nous
devons en permanence analyser au sein de
l'inspection l'usage de ces armes la
quantification avec je vous l'ai indiqué
le traitement du suivi de l'usage des
armes c'est aussi un devoir qui s'impose
à nous et le tout pour en dégager des
idées forces et pour permettre ensuite à
l'institution police nationale d'adapter
si besoin il était ces armes que ce soit
le lanceur de balle de défense que vous
aviez pu évoquer que ce soit le pays qui
peut aussi être évoqué à d'autres à
d'autres occasions
et enfin
sur la problématique du contrôle
d'identité dont j'ai déjà largement
parlé aujourd'hui encore une fois il y
aura un rapport dédié qui sera remis au
directeur général de la police nationale
et au préfet de police toutes les
questions ont pu être posées en se
compris celles évoqué d'un récépissé et
ce n'est pas forcément l'idée qui nous
semble devoir être retenu pour le dire
plus clairement qu'il y ait la nécessité
d'une traçabilité des contrôles identité
dans un devoir de bonnes connaissances
de la population c'est une chose d'un
récipissé il faut ici encore ne pas
avoir de réflexion manichéenne et peser
en toute circonstances les avantages et
les inconvénients de ce qui pourrait
paraître en première intention une bonne
idée
merci merci
merci pour enchaîner concernant les
contrôles d'identité en fait en
gendarmerie on s'est rendu compte que il
y avait pas de souci il y avait pas de
problématique c'est pas moi qui le dis
ce sont les chercheurs
Sébastien
oui
notamment donc si vous voulez moi je
suis opposé un récépissé et je l'ai dit
à clairedon un récépissé notamment en
papier que l'on fasse un travail après
numérique etc comme nous l'avons fait
avec le DDD puisqu'en 2022 nous avons
pour la petite information était saisie
parce qu'une maman a été a dit que son
enfant avait été contrôlé originaire du
Mali avait été contrôlé et que c'était
un contrôle officiel nous avons été en
capacité de prouver que 42 contrôlent
d'identité ont été commis dans le laps
de temps de ce contrôle d'identité 42
avec des noms comme monsieur Durand
Monsieur Mohamed
etc donc la diversité française voilà et
le DDD a conclu qu'il n'y avait pas eu
de contre le faciès donc nous sommes
capables de répertorier et de retrouver
en trace puisque chaque fois que vous
allez contrôler quelqu'un vous avez une
trace sur le fichier nous sommes
capables de tracer les gens qui ont été
contrôlés par l'identité
concernant vous parliez des des forces
des armes de force intermédiaire moi je
suis un pharevant défenseur du maintien
des armes de force intermédiaire le
problème n'est pas de les détenir le
problème est de les utiliser le plus
avec le plus de maîtrise c'est pour ça
que mettons le LBD nous avons mis en
place un un superviseur à côté du tireur
parce que à deux on a plus de réserves
on a plus de retenue que quand on est
tout seul donc tout cela si vous voulez
c'est un problème de formation de
commandement de proximité du chef qui va
décider et agir et donc il faut
maintenir cette proportionnalité si vous
supprimez l'ensemble des moyens vous
arrivez à quoi à déshabiller et
finalement à obliger le gendarme à
utiliser son arme à feu exactement ce
que l'on veut éviter concernant le
collège de déontologie du ministère de
l'Intérieur oui comme l'a dit la chef de
l'IGPN nous avons été associés oui j'ai
mis des réserves alors je vous on est là
aussi devant la représentation nationale
pour en parler ces réserves
sont-elles que si vous voulez mon
successeur qui est juste à ma droite qui
est Jean-Michel Gentil magistrat dans
l'ordre de judiciaire comme un
yestimolocuivre fait que demain je
disais que
dans ce collège de déontologie du
ministère de l'Intérieur il n'y aurait
pas de gendarmes qui pourraient si j'ai
moi j'y suis opposé je souhaite qu'il y
a un gendarme qui puisse léger comment
vous pourriez comprendre et comment un
gendarme du train pour y comprendre que
mettons le collège de déontologie de la
médecine il y est aucun médecin à
l'intérieur
incompréhensible pas lisible donc tout
cela des propositions qui sont
aujourd'hui travaillées et je ne doute
pas que nous serons entendu parce que
nous sommes capables d'ajuster bien sûr
de travailler en finesse concernant
merci pour les hommages qui sont rendus
mais la question était de dire comment
un show peut-on prendre de la distance
avec des enquêtes alors qu'on a des
gendarmes blessés c'est comme si vous
disiez que la personne qui a tué Mélanie
Lemay dans le 47 qui l'a percuté j'ai vu
les images c'est d'une d'une atrocité
comment les gendarmes peuvent enquêter
avec la réserve avec
partialité avec la maîtrise en un mot en
un mot mesdames Messieurs le
professionnalisme qui est qui est de
droit qui est droit dans une démocratie
et sous le contrôle là aussi des
magistrats et nous quand nous
intervenons et B nous avons ces mêmes
distances cette même maîtrise et puis je
dois le dire moi j'ai une toute petite
équipe 117 et j'ai des enquêteurs je
j'ai la crème de la crème voilà et c'est
un bonheur voilà concernant concernant
madame Bonneau ça s'adressait à
ça s'adresser à
Agnès si vous le cuivre concernant les
systèmes qui existent ailleurs bien sûr
en les regarde bien sûr nous avons eu un
séminaire avec le DDD mais moi ce que
j'ai remarqué c'est que j'ai jamais
trouvé de système idéal parce que quand
j'ai regardé les nos amis britanniques
mais j'ai regardé qu'il y avait un
problème de corruption à la police
à Londres qui
qui était extraordinaire le Danemark
citait comme exemple on a on a vu aussi
que si vous voulez il n'y a aucun
système qui est idéal et moi je prône le
contrôle comme il a été à plusieurs
niveaux le contrôle externe par le DDD
et je trouve que nous avons un
dispositif qui est qui est opérationnel
qui est qui marche qui marche n'essyons
pas comme on veut le faire souvent de
rechercher ailleurs ce qui pourrait
marcher bien alors que on a aussi en
France une identité voilà concernant
la Ligue des droits de l'homme bon j'ai
j'ai écouté d'ailleurs j'étais en route
pour venir ici j'ai écouté le président
Baudouin avait beaucoup d'assurance
proférées des des affirmations j'ai été
très surpris qu'on puisse écrire plus de
140 pages
comme ça moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il y a quatre enquêtes quatre
enquêtes nous avons saisi des
des heures de vidéo nous enquêtons je
n'ai pas vu et je l'ai dit puisque je
suis passé il y a un mois devant la
CNCDH je n'ai pas eu je n'ai pas vu
alors qu'aujourd'hui tout est filmé vous
le savez la Ligue des droits de l'homme
avec des drones nous n'avons pas le
droit d'avoir des drones à Sainte Céline
mais la Ligue des droits de l'homme
avait des droits et B nous n'avons pas
vu une image d'un gendarme bloquant une
ambulance en revanche moi j'ai vu je
n'ai pas demandé je parle là de façon
très libre puisque je n'ai pas demandé
de compte-rendu et je veux rien savoir
sur l'enquête judiciaire donc je n'ai
rien à révéler de particulier mais ce
que j'ai vu en tant que citoyen j'ai vu
des prospectus délivrés 10 ans de ne pas
aller voir les secours sur place et j'ai
vu la personne qui a été la plus
gravement blessée le Serge déplacer
plusieurs fois alors qu'il était blessé
gravement à la tête alors qu'on sait
très bien qu'il faut pas faire ça donc
moi je me dis
peut-être on veut se
éviter une mise en cause éventuelle mais
en tout cas je suis
serein dans l'attente des des actions de
justice et qui sont conduits et qui sont
menées là aussi sous le contrôle du
procureur de la République et là
concernant les actions et les atteintes
sur nos gendarmes et les gendarmerie moi
aussi je suis inquiet moi je suis je
suis aussi parce que ce sont nos
familles c'est
d'une grande sensibilité et je
terminerai par dire que nous avons créé
au sein de l'iggène une mission de
sûreté de la gendarmerie qui a pour but
aussi de prendre en compte la protection
de de nos unités et les unités vous le
savez il y a les locaux de service mais
aussi il y a les logements concédés par
nécessité absolue de service voilà
président
merci alors je vous rappelle que c'était
d'abord sur les questions et qui vont
occupé la commission des lois il y a une
mission également d'information sur
l'activisme violent qui traitera
certainement des événements de sainte
Soline et qui nous éclairera au moment
de la reddition de de sa mission devant
la Commission de tous que vous avez cité
des actualités qui peuvent nous faire
connaître à ce moment-là s'agissant
votre audition il s'agissait d'une
première audition à la vocation à se
répéter annuellement et donc c'est une
temporalité que je souhaite une
périodicité que je vous communique à
cette occasion il s'agissant enfin de
rapport annuel de l'IGPN je vous serez
reconnaissant Madame la Directrice dans
ce que sera mis en ligne et communiquer
que elle ne soit également adressée
concomitamment à la commission des lois
pour qu'elle soit diffusée à l'ensemble
des membres de la commission je vous
remercie pour cette première et je vous
propose de faire une pause d'un quart
d'heure avant de me retrouver pour la
remise de la mission flash qui était
confiée à nos collègues Marie le bec et
Nicolas sangsue